all right we've talked about the draft
the Detroit Lions hold the third overall
pick there is an urgency in Detroit to
win now in order to save jobs Martha
Firestone Ford made it clear in December
she's sticking with the front office and
coaching staff but she expects more now
what are your thoughts on where the
Lions currently are where they need to
go and what they need to do with that
pick that they hold in the top five Mike
I I guess I understand why you end up
trading darius slay if you're if you're
the brain trust you know of of this team
and and if you're Bob Quinn and Matt
Patricia I I get it I really do but at
some point you've got to start signing
your big players to second contracts and
holding on and building a team okay
because theoretically and I forget it
might have been todd McShea it might
have been Daniel Jeremiah I forget who
but right after the combine and they
said hey the it looks like the Lions
might lose Darius slay so they've got to
take a CUDA they got to sit here hit
number three and take far and away the
best cornerback
in this draft the kid from Ohio state of
coated Jeff a CUDA so and I thought to
myself they've already got on their team
in their organization a really good
shutdown corner and somehow some way
he's gonna walk out the door and you
can't keep doing this when you have the
third pick in the draft you should use
it to really improve your team not to be
like this not to and and again look I
guess Okuda is gonna be better than
darius slay even though i think there's
no question slays the top 10 12 corner
in the NFL but but so i guess i look at
it and i say the lions to me are just
sitting there treading water and you
know to lose one corner then go get
another one and i don't know what
they're gonna do with their pick none of
us do
but to me i think that
that bothers me about the Detroit Lions
right now and the build of the Detroit
Lions yeah and look one of the realities
that's going on in Detroit now and we
saw it play out in the comments of
Darius slay made to Dave Burke head of
the turret Free Press on his way out the
door the culture change is still a work
in progress and I know that when guys
leave New England they leave Bill
Belichick they believe they're gonna do
things their own way what they don't
realize is his ways are baked into who
they are as coaches it's all they've
known it's all they've seen format
Patricia was 1415 years of watching Bill
Belichick do what he does one of the
things Darius lay complains about is
that Patricia put up film of Slade
getting abused by a receiver in a
practice session and Schley didn't like
that well Bill Belichick did that all
the time
to Tom Brady and everyone else prior
regimes in Detroit apparently didn't
call out the star players who had bad
plays in practice that is an example a
tangible example of the clash of a team
that's been crap all due respect for 60
years and a guy who comes in with 14
years of experience working for the the
gold standard the platinum standard
organization in the NFL and it's taking
time to make it mesh because the guys
who were there under a much more
lackadaisical regime are finding out
that they don't like it with Matt
Patricia they're doing things whether he
realizes it or not the patriot way and I
think with that third overall pick Peter
what they need to be sure they do is
find a guy who's going to be all-in with
the way they do things in New England
and ideally I'm a firm believer and when
you have multiple needs trade down and
get more lottery tickets and hope you
get more winners and try to find more
guys who will come in and convert that
culture to what it is that Matt Patricia
and Bob Quinn are trying to put in
Detroit Mike do you remember this is a
long time ago and you were still a
stately Mike Florio Esquire lawyer in
West Virginia at the time but do you
remember I think it was Labor Day
weekend 2003 where the New England
Patriots cut lawyer Malloy
and they wanted them to take a pay cut
he said absolutely no way even though
you know it had just been like a year
previous that they had won a Super Bowl
then they didn't make the playoffs the
next year and now they were entering
2003 so you know Belichick had been
there three years he had won one Super
Bowl yeah it allows a year the first
year an okay year the third year and
they didn't and they won a Super Bowl in
a shock in year two so he wasn't Bill
Belichick yet okay and lawyer Milloy
just ripped the Patriots for how they
did business and so on that first day of
the season you know after the Patriots
lost 31 to nothing there was a news
report - Malloy - Malloy yeah yeah yeah
and Tom Jackson of ESPN had said on ESPN
on that Sunday the New England Patriots
players hate their coach okay and so I
am getting into what you are saying
right now and we all know so the
Patriots won the Super Bowl that year
they wanted the next year and they would
go on to win it three more times you
know in the last 15 years
so so but my point overall is I believe
that even though Belichick had won one
Super Bowl at the time he was trying to
make one of his defensive leaders take a
pay cut that he wasn't established to be
able to do these kind of things yet and
have the players just roll over whereas
now he kind of has they kind of have to
just roll over whatever he decides even
if it's Tom Brady in bill we trust you
know and so to me I kind of look at this
Mike is a little bit of the same thing
does Matt Patricia if he shows film of
of Darius Leigh getting beat should he
be doing that I think so and I but but
if he's going to be doing that then his
team has to trust that this guy really
knows what he's doing and Tom Brady into
2007 when Randy Moss and Donte
Stallworth walked into the team for the
first time and in the first team meeting
of the offseason in 2007
there's Randy Moss and Donte Stallworth
sitting together in the audience and
they've got a team meeting there's
whatever 6070 people in there and Bill
Belichick puts on tape of Tom Brady
making a crappy throw and throwing an
interception late in the previous season
and he said and Belichick says Brady
what the hell is this I could get Johnny
Foxborough to throw a better ball than
this and Randy Moss and Donte Stallworth
looked at each other and said Dorothy we
are not in Kansas anymore he's saying
that about the best quarterback in the
NFL and but he could say that it was the
same reason why Bill Parcells could say
that stuff about Phil Simms you know in
1987 and 88 because they had won a Super
Bowl and he had established himself in
his program as being so great so and
again I don't think that Matt Patricia
is doing a dumb thing by doing that but
it just goes to show you that the
players don't have that kind of respect
for Patricia maybe that the players in
New England have for Belichick you know
it's funny the thing you mentioned the
same dynamic played out four years later
when Chad Johnson or Oh Joe Cinco
whichever surname he was going by at the
time was traded to the Patriots first
meeting taped from the divisional round
loss to the Jets the prior year after
the lockout right all the crap they got
to do to get a team ready with no
offseason program first team meeting
ripping Tom Brady for his performance
against the Jets in a game they lost to
Rex Ryan and company and Chad was like
holy crap if he's held to that standard
we're all held to that standard and it
works because they won that's the
challenge Peter if you're gonna be that
way you got to get the players to buy in
the quickest way in the easiest way the
most effective way to get them buying is
to win so that's why the clock's ticking
on Matt Patricia he's not going to be
able to force this culture change on the
Lions and get them to buy into it unless
they win because if they're going to be
mediocre it may as well be the way it
was before where it wasn't the coaches a
butthole and if the coach is gonna be a
butthole you better win or people are
gonna check out the media is gonna be
all over you and the next thing you know
you're the latest Lions coach to get
fired I'd still take two at number three
I take to a may the best man win the job
and next year you go you get a one for
Matthew Stafford I mean well I know what
it'd kill you on the cap I get it but I
don't know I do not like it used to not
like it used to doesn't kill you like it
used to I mean the the Lions got ya
Calvin Johnson and Donna can sue in
Matthew Stafford all back in the days
before the rookie Wade scale so it's not
gonna cost what it did and there may be
some wisdom in that to the extent that
you can develop him the way you wanted
to be and I think Toa
will do whatever I mean he survived with
Nick Saban for crying out loud
he'll do whatever Matt Patricia tells
him to do he is preconditioned to deal
with a Bill Belichick type of a head
coach so I I agree with you give him a
year to sit behind Matthew Stafford
worry about Stafford next year and get
to a ready for 2021
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports